voir comment on pourrait passer l'hiver
caché là dedans d'après le temps y'a
rien à faire amour
on s'en va courir toujours mais aux
journaux mais non
moi je m'en vais tuer le
avant l'orage traité sur des sables
je suis comme tous les enfants de
je manque de rien mais brille en souvent
à contre-courant de
héritage l'orage le temps s'est écoulé
chez les pêches mirage de tokaï et
décoder
enfin sans rage ce soir dont les
prochaines années venant dans le sillage
paysage de ta vie retrouvée mais non ya
pas de drame en nous sommeille un vaka
gardons en mémoire ce message présage de
pouvoir trêve et son jeu céleste qu'on a
compté sur nos doigts le forez ce n'est
qu'à quelques pas c'est notre tour
dans tous les soirs on finira quelque
part
les santons mais nos chats hors des murs
de notre dame où traînait sur des scènes
bleus
nous sommes comme tous les enfants de
usage manquerait en nombre et en sauvant
à contre courant de notre héritage
l'orage le temps s'est écoulé
arrachez les pêches mirage des cahiers
d'écolier
enfin son rêve ce soir dans les
prochaines années
venant dans le siège usage de ta vie
retrouvée à l'eau
l'horreur à l'oms de l'orage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]